hello and welcome back to Five Nights at
Freddy's I'm rolling right everything's
good everything's great good so we've
got a puzzle and that puzzle is going to
be
solved not exactly sure
how but it's going to be solved so we've
got trash can
chica so
obviously this is
here so I'm just going to look really
closely at this
nonsense bugs welcome Freddy fazar
Fazbear theater trash the next show will
begin in 5 minutes we are still open
still open still open still
open
uh-huh
if I just eat everything is that going
to
work
ow is that chica hi okay so you what is
your
deal trash can Wait trash can Trash Can
trash can Trash Trash Trash Trash
Trash okay trash hi yeah there you go
trash trash right
trash Oh I drank one of those
sorry hi chica okay so it's got to be
there's no one out there right okay good
it's got to be
something
H right chica chug chica bar chica
chug chica chug CH did I put everything
in
these trash can Trash Can trash can
Trash Trash Can trash can Trash Can
trash can Trash Trash Trash popcorn
trash
popcorn
trash where are you I hear
you
oh where are you okay there's something
here it gives me a lot of time in this
first
space so that must be time to do
something
right there's the
um I just realized I didn't do the this
thing I do that
oh that's not a good combo all right
it's
specific it's that one with the meat
bites maybe that's it I got to throw
away every combination of thing before
that goes
there okay so that was what was it chica
tuug plus lemon
bar
uh-huh oh God I don't know if I'm going
to make this
well there goes that okay techno cooler
with the color the color matches to the
color so that's simple enough come on
come on come
on
okay that goes there for the is that
butter butter for
[Music]
one
okay well I'm going to die I think I'm
going to
die I did it give me my wow
okay okay so that wasn't quite
it that's all
right
so maybe I did get
it maybe that was it welcome to Freddy
Fazbear's Fazbear theater the next show
will begin in 5 minutes maybe that was
it still open still open God damn you so
maybe I'm going to try that again
welcome to
Freddy theater the next show will begin
in 5 minutes we are still okay that's
all that hot dog goes in cheese goes
in Red Bull goes
in Pizza goes in popcorn is in going to
get this going that's sodon with the
meat
bites okay oh frick I did popcorn go in
I think it went in meat pretzel goes in
in this goes in this goes in chica chug
the Chica
bar wait a minute okay hold on let me
finish this
thought I I know let me fish that
thought I get in there okay whatever you
go in there with oh the butter no
not this this goes
in I just had a
thought she
CH okay whatever I just put everything
in no not
that this with ketchup put that there oh
freak of
course all right whatever it's fine
pizza
slice
all right lemon chica
bar disappointment
chips lemon chica bar two lemon chica
bars okay so the trash can had
four chica things in them there's one
there's only two chica things
here unless is there something in there
no okay I'm just going to I'm going to
finish this
out I'm just going to finish this
out yeah hurry up I know it's right
you're welcome
Tata okay pretzel with ketchup weird but
okay um sodon blendy God damn it I
forgot about this
stuff okay pizza slice with ketchup
that's
weird not questioning it uh-huh I know
disappointment chips and two sodar Ronis
which are meat bite based I know what
the
freak
hi
one
[Music]
there's no one out there right
good all
right
T oh did I put one of each drink in
there by itself what pretzel had ketchup
what do you mean pretzel didn't have
ketchup what you talking about did I put
one of these
in I don't know if I did but just in
case I got to get moving on this how did
the how are you telling me that that
didn't
have the right thing in it cuz it did
that definitely has ketchup unless it
got knocked out somehow I don't
know okay dis boyman chips two sodon
blendies and a pizza slice with ketchup
you got it sure there you go now it's
ready
okay that is
correct oh what do you
mean oh wait no it had
ketchup that's ridiculous okay so I
don't know if that's the right strategy
to just throw everything
away doesn't make any sense wel to
Freddy Fazbear's Fazbear theater the
next show will begin in 5 minutes it
doesn't really make sense but it kind of
makes sense chica chug with
bar away this with water for
one why did they just disappear why did
why did that just disappear I it's gone
why okay and that that should be
everything that should be everything
thrown away so what we need now chowder
with ketchup definitely ketchup chatter
with ketchup disappointment
chips meat
bites chica
chug and a DJ
blendy there you
go okay so wait you better not count
that as not being on there because
that's your fault yeah that's right
that's what I thought okay so I got a
free I think that's a DJ blendy DJ
techno cooler you got
it exotic beverage you got
it let's see lemon chica bar you oh did
I put all these in I don't know if I did
just in case lemon chica bar is in there
pizza slice with nacho
cheese nacho cheese you got it bam
roxxy's Nacho goes with
butter now technically I haven't done
every combination of say like the
coverings but the toppings you know I
wouldn't really call them toppings
because they're more coverings than
anything thank you
Tata exotic blendy of course is the one
that I don't have ready butter for
one that there give me that chunk oh my
God I see you in the darkness there okay
sodon blendy you got it sodon coming up
with meat bites that's there that's
there you're there rocking
nachos with ketchup weird but
okay hi buds hold
on okay and then popcorn with ketchup
very strange but all right
Casa that clears them out I'm just going
to throw this away cuz I don't remember
what it
was okay sodon you got it sodon in there
pop a new one in there two butter for
ones Chuck okay nachos with
ketchup oh that's close that's a little
close for my taste and then popcorn with
butter wow something normal there we
go okay we're all good
there
okay chica chug chica
chug sodon blendy meat bites in there
that there techno
cooler disappointment chips sardoni
blendy lemon CH bar pretzel just PL old
pretzel uh pizza slice with nacho cheese
you got it pizza slice nacho cheese
done
oh what what do you mean pretzel I
literally oh is this Ah that's meat
pretzel this is
pretzel okay all right yeah yeah yeah
whatever with nro cheese okay so that's
where I went wrong with the last one too
well that's kind of dumb but whatever
that's the one I don't have ready okay
sodon blendy is going to have not that
meat bites put that there bam in there d
J techno cooler chica chug coming up
just in case I have to again
bam that's it okay that got
it
[Music]
okay oh okay well that was easy I didn't
even need to deal with monsters so that
I see what it is
now
I don't think anything happened though I
feel like with the last
one oh
FL that's kind of nice I feel like with
the last one there was definitely some
instantaneous effect
right did I get fla yes I
did delicious so there's four things
there's four Chas and I was H I had this
thought I had this just thought
that there's four are there four is one
of
these like cuz it's it's like a Roxy
rocking nachos Fazbear theater the next
show will begin I got to figure out
which one of these is going to
be which one of these is actually like
chica's specific thing because if it's
like chica's lemon bar a chica chug
right you throw throw that
in you throw that
in and then you make a
combination that's another chica thing
technically and then
there's one of these is a chica thing
she loves pizza maybe that's
it and then
Pizza huh is that it nah it would tell
me it there would be something that said
oh that was a thing you know there would
be a thing let me restart until the menu
is going to say what it is right at some
point it's going to tell me specifically
oh this is a chica thing okay tell me
what this is I need to know which one of
these is it chica's
chowder was it chica chowder was it
chowder chowder for
chica chowder Roxy's rocking it's got to
be right maybe that is it okay so we got
oh damn
you you go there you go there you go
there and then put the chowder in huh
who whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa oh do I need to finish it I
probably need to finish it right I
probably need to finish this okay let's
make an exotic
blendy the butter for one in there yeah
I know okay so we need rocking nachos
with extra cheese that's gross popcorn
with butter that's very
normal popcorn with butter chica chug
chica chug and then exotic blendy you
got it bam in
there okay what I had it the this is so
dumb it was literally right there but
whatever
sure
butter and then it was an exotic
blendy whoa
oops little dumb but it's
[Applause]
okay oh blendy ah
frick I didn't see that blendy okay just
kill me you know what actually I'm not
even going to let you kill me
okay but I was right about the the trash
so it was chica's Chowder so it's chica
chowder chicaa lemon bar chica drink
chica
blendy there it is okay so I probably do
have to finish this out without dying to
be able to do this right we need chowder
with cheese it was tricky it wasn't even
going to tell me it was who was chica
chowder specifically meat bites butter
for one lemon chick bar
easy
okay thank you
Tata okay chowder with
cheese chowder with cheese nachos with
butter you got it sodon blendy with meat
bites in
there and then we got an exotic beverage
just the
beverage just the beverage and two sodon
blendies okay A little problematic but
that's not
bad all
right okay we're good
there there put that
there all right disappointment chips
meat bites sodon blendies up the app
[Music]
getting good at this I don't know if I
should be proud of being good at this
but I am getting good at this record
time all
right thank
you rocket nachos with ketchup oh we got
a meat pretzel with butter weirdly
enough and then we got a hot dog with
hot dog with butter hot dog with butter
okay don't move butter for one then an
exotic beverage B Be Babble
boo okay we're prepped and ready for the
next one come on chica what do you need
what do you need what do you need what
do you need tell me oh boy meat pretzel
with cheese we got a pizza SL slice just
straight up wo my okay I ate that that's
fine I was hungry pizza slice meat
pretzel with
cheese Okay I hold on there lemon chica
bar soda
Roni chica chug just chaug and and then
a soda Ron blendy with meat
bites that there don't move don't move
don't move okay that didn't that didn't
get you anyway but it's okay all right
what ch Oh chaug e God every time with
that crap don't mess me up now please
don't mess me
up I know I know okay it's a chica chug
e and then a sodon blend
D sodon blend D and then a regular
sodon lemon CH bar and meat pretzel with
cheese two meat pretzels with cheese two
meat pretzels with cheese and then a
pizza slice ice that I'm not going to I
ate again that's weird Okay lemon chica
bar
sodon let's see this and then a regular
sodon bam boom done thank you thank
you chicka
[Music]
chuggy yep t t woo I did it and I got
the weird thing out of the trash can
which is
great
okay what did I get oh yeah all right so
that so that was correct right
oh hi you want some
FL
fla fla okay more for me so that's gone
now what are you oh there it is okay
so it's balora on a door
right right this is just me really
reaching but it's balora on a door the
only
door is the door in her
Gallery oh maybe okay wait wait wait
wait wait
if I do this I didn't even think about
it before but what I forgot to
do was maybe look around the door at the
end of the hallway
right for your safety please make your
way to the exit please make your way
there a door there in 5 minutes 4 3 1
minute to
exit
oh
oh I knew it I knew there was like still
that ticking going on I should have
known that all
right that's my bad but there's a door
at the end I've gone the other way and
that didn't do anything so there has to
be something at the end of this
hallway
[Music]
so my question is is there something
special about this door what is inside
cannot that way we will see you again
soon someone is
inside we will see you again
H I can't climb the
pipes it's the only door I know
of the door is
[Music]
closing if I cross over the thresh so of
the
door maybe I go
[Music]
back
it's almost like when I'm over here she
doesn't
spawn so is there something about this
door oh cuz I imagine if it closes it's
just going to be game over
right I don't think that there's any
secret for
losing there doesn't seem to be anything
about the door that's
special
hey hey
balora hey
balora hey hey
balora
hey
Bora Bora
a
b
Bora
balora balora give me your
cigarettes not cigarettes I meant
secret I don't know there's someone on
the other side of this door no as soon
as I go over there it's going to it's
going to game over well game win but
then you know the game is over and I
can't go either direction because
there's nothing
there well it's not even letting me
cross over now oh that's
weird
nope
oh okay wait a
minute I did
hear right at the end there there was a
little bit of a grindy sound right there
was just the tiniest bit of a grindy
sound okay well I can't hit that button
cuz I'm in the wrong
spot I I think that'll help so maybe
it's something to do with that I don't
know maybe waiting at the door and it
closes at the door was going to be the
thing and I just didn't wait around long
enough but there might be another thing
that I'm not remembering
hey wow look at you Bonk Bonk Bonk
Swank no no you fell oh there's no other
Clues
right it's all the same hm okay so those
two were both in this world that's where
I got the story so it might be something
the only place that Bora is is in that
one I think oh I haven't done I haven't
done the fazer blast I forgot about that
fizzy Faz night I also haven't done let
me H my work is fulfilling and I am
happy every day I sure am okay make the
correct order use double time if you
need resources quickly okay supervisor
wants his special orders quickly okie
dokie
then all right I'm ready M A okay you
are back
Isa you are going to have to play a bit
of catch up push St harder use double
time button make them work faster okay I
will all right what is
that a yes gug
glug okay um double
time I think anyway salt is still not
available H okay so ah this is a problem
every freaking time with this
thing
hi can I help you I'm sorry oh I go on
my own oh executive order do this order
do this order what hold on wait I what
hold on I'm figuring things
out hold on acid acid
sugar okay I I did it do I give that to
you or what do you want do I do I do oh
boy there they're
all I wasn't paying attention to the
okay whatever all right see you around
I'm going to lose this one but it's okay
oh what's with all
that what's with all that whoa w oh my
God oh my God oh oh
okay I don't need to be in height adjust
mode thank
you okay
um okay all right good um everyone
happy double time all right we really
got to get into
this okay I'll get that in a second
double time chica take a break chica all
right well chica took a break
double
time let's see double time double time
time Hello Goodbye okay oh oh oh no I'm
dead
ah that yeah I I I deserve that I do I
do I do I
do I I deserve that I
understand that was my bad clock and job
start now
uh-huh can we go can we hey wake up wake
up wake up we got work to do double time
baby double time double time double time
double time all right what do we got
protein protein come on we got to get
going all right what's up hey oh boy all
right what do you
want acid caffeine sugar there we go
that's going out there what do you want
okay you need a break break double time
double time double time okay yes do this
order okay caffeine caffeine
sugar protein
acid okay I did that oh boy take a break
double time double time double time
let's go let's go let's go okay protein
man where are you come on protein man
all right I'm just going to miss this
one cuz double time double time double
time double
time all right I'm going to miss this
one just cuz I want to stockpile some
stuff yeah I know I missed that one but
I can miss
one let see protein okay protein protein
acid sugar caffeine okay I'll wait on
that oh you need a break you need a
break soon double time double
time yeah I
know break double time protein let's go
and send it
out thankfully I don't have salt oh boy
you again okay what do you
want okay yep I know break
what sugar caffeine caffeine acid
protein okay you were just looking okay
I I appreciate
that okay you need a break as well all
right you
understood being caffeine Sugar Sugar
acid going to let that one sit you need
a
break all right let's go let's go let's
go double
time okay double time
protein all what's up
hello okay let's send that one
out double time double time double time
double
time okay what do we
need okay protein protein acid acid acid
caffeine put it in double time double
time double time double time this is
great I like being there boss this makes
my life so
easy y'all don't even need
brakes and send it out bye oh boy okay
what do you
need what's up what's up double time
double time double time double time
what
what protein protein acid sugar caffeine
all right you're just looking okay you
need a break you got it you're going to
need a break okay all right so I just
need to give them brakes and whenever
these come
up you go double
time you go double
time break you go double time double
time double time your break double time
oh oh God damn
it well I wasn't paying attention to
that sure did miss out on that
opportunity that's
fun there two busy giving double times
around that I completely neglected to do
what I needed to do which is always fun
come
on break break break okay you double
time double double double send it
up you're on a break you're coming up on
your break double time double time
double time
what what sugar
caffeine caffeine protein acid
what okay whatever double time double
time break double
time all right I can't make another
mistake so I might have just made a
mistake who knows okay we're full up on
all the
goodies okay protein protein acid acid
sugar
Wham okay double time double time double
time double time
I didn't even need to do lock down this
is going swimmingly they all love me oh
break hello
again mhm break come
on okay acid acid protein protein
caffeine ready to rock who don't spill
ready to
rock okay see double double double
I still don't have
salt yeah what what you going to
actually talk to me or
what did I do it see
around all right well that was
easy
d oh God I hope not I really hope
not CH oh a message
for confection Corner confectioner
Corner oh what am I looking
at what what am I looking at also
where's
that can I may I
may ah this isn't demonetizing at all
anyway that's uh kind of
terrible what do you have to say for
yourself
honk okay so what does this
mean is
it sodon oh not another
one how could there be another there
wouldn't be two things in that theater
one I guess could be the one of the
other ones so there's a graveyard so
that probably means one of the Fazbear
fright levels which could
be Faz
Blass it could be that one whoa wait a
minute oh no wait that was something
else was it food prep no wasn't it
there where wait a minute where was
that ah fizzy Faz Knight
4 okay interesting but where would there
be
didn't this wasn't this a
graveyard I believe this had the
graveyard in it
right don't forget the targets on your
sides ooh use fazer blast on the light
sensors balls on the target dark guns on
the balloons don't then the push babies
near you yeah I know all right let's
just take a look at
this back again to SK well here's
another one from the
Vault look this is the last time there's
nothing left the final
challenge the final
challenge uh-huh okay
so oh jeez
hey I got you a little what' you give
me oh what the freak oh hey what's
up well that's a
problem oh boy there we go well that's
concerning what's that
about wait a minute no what do I do oh
oh oh oh oh my God okay well that was
horrible oh no that's not
good
oh okay that's awful oh hi all
right okay all right is there oh my God
Jes Zs oh oh what what what
what what the
freak what is happening oh my
god oh hey all right that's weird okay I
am so
confused I am super duper confused but
that's okay I don't need to be anything
but not oh my God you okay that's
been
got this is so
[Music]
weird is are those actually poppable
balloons
no okay I'm not finding anything to be
able to do my score oh my God okay
you're there know that I know I know
it's it's not my
intention wa okay all right so what is h
i I am so
confused oh my
God feel like those are the only things
that are going to give me
points
what the freak is going
on damn
it damn
you see I can't tell if I'm actually
doing okay or
not I haven't needed to do the balloons
in a while go
away why am I checking these cameras
what is the point oh my God what do I
oh ah oh my
God ah damn it damn
it oh my God where
where
where with a prise put the little one
next time bring the whole family for one
the lifetime G
barod okay I don't know what I
did I I don't feel like I did what I was
supposed to
do I don't feel
like I don't feel like I
succeeded something has
changed a
message for stage really here or there
not seeing a message oh oh
oh well I just saw some
tentacles I just had
that I don't know and the rocket ship is
clearly from the fazer blast
games
but rocket
ship I mean I missed the rocket ship at
the end of this one I know I and there's
a rocket the with each of these so did I
hang on let me what one second hold on
pause for a
moment
H let me just see
something was there a rocket chip in all
of these okay this oh it might be this
one cuz this definitely had space
theming the other ones weirdly did not
but this one definitely
did
come
on there's that rocket ship okay that
didn't do anything
[Music]
okay rocket
ship ah there it was there there there
that that
[Music]
that
okay
no not over
[Music]
yet it's for the whole
family now you look like you got kids WI
a prize for the little one with next
time bring the whole family for once in
a lifetime H Ino
barrier did I miss
something
B bon bon great
why I just feel like I'm missing
something is Bon Bon on here how would
bon bon even be on this stage there's
bon
bon well hey you little douchebag if
only I had my
Mallet damn
it
sh all
right okay so as much of a genius as I
am to solve things like that there's a
couple more that I'm not fully
understanding but no one spoil a damn
thing if you spoil this for me I will
hunt you down and gut you like a
fish who do you think you are to tell me
what I should do I know it that's just
future me that knows it and you don't
want to mess with future me you don't
want to mess with future me at all so
don't even try don't even
try I nailed my own spit so I'm going to
leave while I still have dignity thank
you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye